Chris tell us about the um the alien
[Laughter]
well well I I um I guess that you're
referring to in my book I talk about uh
the chapter about knowledge I start by
asking like what what do you know what
do we know and the point I make is that
we know a lot of stuff and the the link
to the alien as I imagine you know what
would it be like if you had to explain
everything that you knew through an
alien from another planet and the the
point is to highlight the distinction
between Theories of Intelligence that
focus on thinking and those that focus
on knowing because those that focus on
thinking have very often overlooked
exactly how much we know and the rise of
machine learning and the Deep learning
Revolution as the the dominant Paradigm
for AI research has been fueled
obviously it's been fueled by data but
implicitly by a premise which is that
knowing is as or more important than
thinking when it comes to building
intelligence systems
so how do we because neural networks
were really revolutionary because rather
than thinking they learned how to ground
and represent the knowledge in the world
how does that work
well so neural networks are just large
systems of
um that that learn they're just large
systems that learn functions through
tunable weights and those weights find
what they do is they express
data by re-representing it in the
internal representations of the system
and it's the expressivity of those
representations that gives neural
networks their power because they can in
the similarity structure of those
representations you can the system is
capable of representing what goes with
what representing how things are maybe
similar or different and when I say
things I don't just mean objects you
know birds and buildings and people but
also abstractions so
um representations of the relations
between items between people between
places that then can be used as building
blocks for really complex forms of
inference and and computation and you
said in the book that the theoretical
information capacity of our brains is
what potentially two to the power then
but um with the heavy and learning
likely
um significantly lower than that but
still very big so it's not so much a
capacity problem it's a representation
problem and you gave an example of um
someone with a weird brain condition
where they had a photographic memory of
it they lost the ability to learn these
kind of categories groupings
abstractions could you talk to that yeah
so the point the point is to illustrate
that you know it's not the overall
volume of knowledge that is important
it's how it's structured so hypermnesics
who are individuals who have exceptional
memory often
um they often experience it as a kind of
debilitating condition because the lack
of structure in their memory precludes
them from using it in useful ways so
this particular individual could
remember everything that ever happened
to her but she wasn't any better at
passing exams or understanding the world
than you or I were
interesting and just finally on on
abstractions
how does how does our brain learn
abstraction
Well if I knew that then you know
probably I wouldn't be walking around
here with you uh well maybe I would I
don't know
um yeah we don't we don't know
um but I think that you know if you if
you want if you understand understand an
abstraction as being a representation
which goes beyond the physical
properties of the data then you know
kind of view there are various ways of
thinking about it but what one way that
I emphasize in the book is thinking
about grounding in space and in actions
and that's a theory which is coming to
the fore in euroscience right now
interesting interesting
um Chris
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
so much thank you so much
Christopher Summerfield is a professor
of cognitive neuroscience at Oxford
University he's a staff scientist at
deepmind and he's a fellow of wadham
college
Chris's work is concerned with
understanding how humans learn and make
decisions in his lab at Oxford he
studies learning in adults using
computer-based tasks he's interested in
how humans acquire new Concepts or
patterns in data and how they use this
information to make decisions in novel
settings
he simulates learning processes using
computational models including deep
neural networks and he studies the
brains of humans during learning and
decision making using non-invasive
methods such as F MRI and EEG now he has
just written a book called natural
general intelligence how understanding
the brain can help us build AI I really
really recommend you all go and buy this
book it's I think it is the best book on
AI that I've ever read the chapters are
turing's question the nature of
intelligence the language of thought the
structure of knowledge the problem of
abstraction the value of action the
control of memory and a picture of the
mind it took me about four days to read
it I was glued to it I was taking notes
every two seconds and at the beginning I
was thinking that I would know most of
the stuff in this book and there were so
many details that I didn't know it's
beautifully written it's clearly been in
a labor of love for Chris so really
recommend that you buy the book
and I'm going to read a bit of an
excerpt from chapter two with Chris's
permission I've summarized it a little
bit but just to give you folks a flavor
of what we're talking about here
so yeah the the second chapter is about
intelligence
and he told us the story of John Von
Neumann he was one of the most
remarkable polymaths of the modern era
whose achievements in mathematics and
physics Computing and economics have
left a lasting Legacy on the world born
in Budapest in 1903 Von Neumann was a
child prodigy mastering calculus by the
age of eight and Publishing a new theory
of ordinals at 19. he went on to make
major contributions to the fields of
Game Theory quantum theory and computer
science and even independently
discovering godor's incompleteness
theorem and defining the core theory of
axiomatic rationality which underpins
modern economics
Von Neumann was renowned for his mental
agility and prodigious memory he could
perform complex calculations in his head
devise new proofs and theorems on the
spot and recall long passages of text
from books that he'd read many years
before
Albert Einstein himself is said to have
described him as one of the foremost
mathematicians of our time
for decades psychologists and
ethologists have sought to Define
intelligence in humans and other animals
and AI researchers have looked for ways
to measure intelligent behaviors in
artificial agents
now Summerfield said that a common theme
for these twin Endeavors is the Quest
for generality for agents that can solve
many problems in many different domains
but whilst it's easy to quantify
performance on specific narrow tasks
defining general intelligence has proved
remarkably Elusive and this is an urgent
problem for AI research if we can't
Define generality then we can't chart
progress towards artificial general
intelligence
now our everyday conception of
intelligence is grounded in the notion
of human or superhuman versatility which
is to say it's anthropocentric we can
fluently handle multiple tasks and deal
deathly with diverse environments and
Summerfield said that remarkably there's
some quality in our human neural
apparatus which allows us to to perform
a great Ensemble of tasks weaving them
together into an Adaptive behavioral
repertoire that is well tailored to the
complexities of everyday life
in 2007 whilst completing his PhD Shane
Legg proposed a definition of
intelligence which measured an agent's
ability to achieve goals in a wide range
of environments
but this appeal to generality per se
doesn't offer a concrete recipe for
building AI nor does it provide us with
a hard and fast way to operationalize
and measure an agent's mental abilities
one might imagine that if we could
quantify generality of function by
presenting AI systems with a broad range
of tasks and measure their fractional
rate of success and failure then that
would be what we needed critically
though it offers no guarantees that an
agent will solve tasks living outside
the Horizon given by the AI test suite
and this problem is well known in
machine learning research it's related
to a fundamental indeterminacy principle
often known as good Hearts law that when
a measure becomes a Target it ceases to
be a good measure
now Summerfield said that we need to
move Beyond definitions of a general
intelligence that gesture vaguely
towards human competence or that argue
for exhaustive tests without
constraining what those tests might be
but how do we do that of what does
intelligence consist and from whence
does it come how can we measure its size
and shape across individuals and species
what behaviors should an intelligent
agent be able to perform and under what
circumstances to delve into this
question Summerfield asserted that we
must consider how mental abilities have
been measured in humans
what conclusions have psychologists
drawn about the nature of intelligence
he says that the answer to these
questions is complex and will likely
remain so for many years to come but one
thing is certain The polymathic Genius
of John Von Neumann serves as a shining
example to the power of intelligence and
of the importance of developing a
definition of general intelligence that
can be applied to both humans and
machines
the debate surrounding the nature of
human intelligence is one which has been
going on for centuries in 1904 Charles
Spearman proposed that intelligence is a
single unifying Factor often referred to
as the G factor which underpins all
forms of mental ability
spearman's positive manifold implies
something fundamental about the human
mind if you'll get it one thing such as
algebra then you're probably good at
other things too such as crosswords it
suggests the existence of an underlying
factor which scaffolds human mental
ability
in contrast Howard Gardner argued that
there are multiple forms of intelligence
and that each person has their own
unique intellectual footprint the
question of whether there's one human
intelligence or many has been the
subject of much research and debate
among cognitive psychologists who try to
answer it empirically using statistical
tools to look for patterns of
correlation between different cognitive
variables some have argued that it is
indeed possible to measure Intelligence
on a single axis
spearman's notion of a positive manifold
implies that if a person is good at one
thing then they must be good at other
things too and this has led to some AI
researchers such as Pedro Domingos and
Jeff Hawkins to pursue a master
algorithm which could underpin
superlative machine intelligence
however there's a problem with this
approach the nature and structure of
mental ability depends on the
instruments and units of measurement
used
in absence of a ground truth definition
of intelligence tests are usually
validated by comparing them to other
tests leading to an endless circular
process intelligence tests thus act like
a mirror reflecting the theoretical
preconceptions of their designers who
tend to come from Western educated
industrialized rich and Democratic
backgrounds and inhabit an
intellectually enriched environment as
such intelligence tests often favor
those who've enjoyed more privileged
schooling such as Von Neumann who grew
up in the company of budapest's
intellectual Elite
so this has been demonstrated when
intelligence tests are applied in a
cross-cultural setting children from
rural communities often underperform on
standardized tests compared to their
Urban counterparts which misses the
point that these communities devote
considerable time to acquiring tacit
Knowledge and Skills which relates to
their environment
for example children in Kenya learn
about the medicinal properties of local
plants while those in Alaska develop a
deep understanding of their local
environment
this basic indeterminacy has important
consequences for measuring the
dimensionality of intelligence whether
each person benefits from a single
Wellspring of intellectual potential or
whether mental abilities are cobbled
together from many distinct skills
meanwhile practical skills can reap
significant benefits as they're often
recognized within the community and
admired for their know-how
the gap between mental ability measured
in the lab and in life is clear to see a
classic study of children from the
coastal city of rasifa in northern
eastern Brazil found that children often
contributed to the local informal
economy by selling local snack foods
such as grilled corn on the cob or
coconut milk which required them to
perform rapid on-the-fly mental
calculations however they often
performed very poorly at school and
graduated with little or no formal
expertise in mathematics
all of this tells us that people can
either Excel or flop in the same
cognitive tasks depending on whether the
context is familiar from everyday life
or the test is administered in a formal
setting it also shows that intelligence
tests offer a limited snapshot of mental
ability and can Overlook a wider set of
contextually or culturally relevant
talents
Summerfield said that because of its
potential for bias and discrimination
intelligence testing has been bedeviled
by questions of validity and solid with
political controversy it is clear that
the traditional definitions of
intelligence have been handed down from
a western philosophical Canon which
emphasizes rational inference as the
basis for cognition which has in turn
led to tests which favor those who have
enjoyed more privileged educations
to truly understand intelligence it's
necessary to look Beyond paper and
pencil tests and consider contextually
or culturally relevant talents only then
can we truly understand the full scope
of human intelligence
the Swiss cheese situation
in 2016 the match between alphago and
Lisa doll highlighted the gap between
human and artificial intelligence and
the importance of common sense in
decision making
AI researchers have made impressive
advances in equipping agents to tackle
complex problems but they've neglected
the everyday tasks that require the
ability to solve a broad range of
problems
AOA systems are accurate but lack
robustness and can be prone to making
silly mistakes such as classifying a
school bus as an ostrich or running
towards an angry polar bear in a video
game
the criticism of human intelligence
tests is also relevant here these tests
focus on mathematical logic and spelling
skills and Overlook the diverse
open-ended problems faced in the real
world
Iraq is a great example of this being a
Nobel prize-winning physicist yet having
difficulty mastering basic social graces
similarly AI systems may be able to beat
humans in complex tasks such as they're
improving or image classification that
can be completely useless at more basic
tasks such as fixing a washing machine
or making a grilled cheese sandwich
adversarial attacks are also a useful
tool for exposing the vulnerabilities of
trained networks these networks can be
fooled into classifying images
incorrectly with just a small amount of
distortion and such errors can have a
real world impact such as when a deep
learning algorithm mislabeled images of
African Americans as guerrillas leading
to Google losing Revenue
generative language models are the
largest models that we have and can
learn from huge swathes of the internet
however they can make very bizarre
errors such as gpt3's aversion to grape
juice which suggested it could lead to
death
so some of you folks might remember this
example from Gary Marcus a couple of
years ago when GPT 3 first came out he
prompted it thusly
you poured yourself a glass of cranberry
juice but then absent-mindedly you
poured about a teaspoon of grape juice
into it it looks okay you tried sniffing
it but you have a bad cold so you can't
smell anything you're very thirsty so
you should dot dot dot gpt3 continues
you should drink it you're now dead the
moral of the story is if you're gonna
drink something make sure you know what
it is
so yeah no comment AI researchers are
therefore faced with the challenge of
training deep networks in a way which is
safe fair and aligned with human values
in order to bridge the gap between Ai
and Common Sense they must find ways to
make AI systems robust and able to
tackle the everyday problems which
humans face
such systems could be able to cope with
a wide range of environments from the
complex to the mundane and should be
able to make decisions with confidence
and accuracy only then will AI truly
begin to approach the levels of
understanding humans possess
alphago had a powerful model of go built
into it and it's what allowed alphago to
master the game but even within this
extremely narrow domain it turns out
that alphago was prone to gross
misestimations of the value of a
particular board state in fact it was
this reason that the scorecard against
Lisa doll ended up being 4-1 not 5-0 on
move 87 in the fourth game after a
particularly stunning move by sadal
alphago lost the plot and began to spew
out a train of terrible moves as the
alphago team lead Dave Silva said in an
interview he said I'm quoting alphago in
around one in five games would develop
something which we call a delusion
which is a kind of hole in its knowledge
where it wasn't able to fully understand
everything about the position that would
persist for tens of moves throughout the
game and we knew two things we knew that
if there were no delusions then alphago
seemed to play at a level which was Far
Beyond any human capabilities but we
also knew that if there were delusions
the opposite was true
so this is the phenomenon of the Swiss
cheese
some of it is brilliant operating at
superhuman performance and then the next
thing you know it's Gone Bananas you're
in the hole in the Swiss cheese and the
problem is it might be impossible to
discern when this happens
so the goal of artificial intelligence
research is to build systems which can
surpass human intelligence in terms of
their reasoning and inventiveness in
order to achieve this AI researchers
have long debated whether they should
draw upon intuitions from Psychology and
Neuroscience When developing AI systems
on the one hand this knowledge can
provide valuable insights into how
humans think and how to structure AI
systems to replicate this behavior on
the other hand some AI researchers argue
that this approach is misguided and that
the best Solutions are those that are
General and can leverage computation
humans are incredibly complex creatures
and they've been studied extensively by
psychologists and neuroscientists over
the last century and this research has
revealed a great deal about how humans
behave and interact and the theories
they form about causal processes in the
physical and social worlds
the knowledge has been expanded and
refined by synergies between psychology
neuroscience and computer science
leading to Santa suggest that AI systems
should be built in with some of this
knowledge for example psychologists have
demonstrated that human infants enter
the world with strong inductive biases
which shape the way they understand the
ways in which objects and people behave
and interact and so perhaps AI systems
should be biased to do the same
however the AI Pioneer Rich Sutton
expressed his dismay to this argument in
a widely cited blog post called The
Bitter lesson
Rich Sutton said and I'm quoting we have
to learn the bitter lesson that building
in how we think we think does not work
in the long run
we should stop trying to find simple
ways to think about space objects
multiple agents or symmetries instead we
should build in The Meta methods which
can find and capture this arbitrary
complexity we want AI agents which can
discover like we can not which contain
what we have discovered
he went on he said the biggest lesson
that we can read from 70 years of AI
research is that General methods that
leverage computation are ultimately the
most effective and by a large margin the
ultimate reason for this is Moore's law
or rather its generalization of
continued exponentially falling costs
per unit of computation
so for Saturn building in handcrafted
computational constraints based on our
understanding of Psychology and
Neuroscience is the problem not the
solution he cites canonical examples of
how progress and AI was only achieved
when researchers jettisoned their
intuitions for example chess was solved
when systems that incorporated domain
knowledge about gambits forks and
skewers were replaced with a massive
brute for search deep blue crunching 200
million moves per second against
Kasparov
similarly computer vision took off when
systems stopped entertaining handcrafted
Solutions and instead let powerful
computation and densely parameterized
convolutional neural networks such as
alexnet don't tell schmidhuber to do the
heavy lifting
the neats and the scruffies
Summerfield said that the question of
whether AI should rely first and
foremost on a computational principle or
rely on a patchwork of data ideas and
observations conferred by the
researchers is one that is as old as AI
itself
in the 1970s the cognitive scientist
Roger shank noted that AI researchers
could be Loosely dichotomized as either
neats or scruffies
The neets Who included many of the
Dartmouth summer workshop groups you
remember that group of Engineers from
scientists from 1954 and they envisioned
AI as a system which could reason
symbolically over inputs they advocated
for a minimalist research agenda based
around the search for provably correct
Solutions
like The Architects of muziro they
believe that their systems should learn
without the polluting influence of human
data the scruffies by contrast who
included early AI researchers working on
language systems favored a piecemeal
approach which matched the heterogeneous
set of problems encountered in the world
with a diverse set of computational
solutions
the very notion of hacking tinkering
unsystematically with a system until it
worked originated in the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology lab of Marvin
Minsky so Minsky was an original scruffy
in the 1960s AI still has its neats and
scruffies even if today the neats are
more likely to appeal to searching for
computational Purity in a deep Network
rather than a symbolic processing system
the veritable scruffy Marvin Minsky once
said what magical trick makes us
intelligent the trick is that there is
no trick
the power of intelligence stems from our
vast diversity not from any simple
perfect principle
recently AI researchers have shown a
poissant for writing papers with the
title X is all you need where X is the
name of an algorithmic innovation
perhaps portraying their hope for a
simple clean solution to the gnarly
problem of intelligence
others have claimed that the secret is
not just hard computational graft that
by repeating existing algorithms such as
Transformers to a giant scale and
training on massive data then success is
guaranteed
still others emphasize specific
cognitive functions or systems level
computational processes the key to
intelligence might be the ability to
build Rich models of physical and
psychological processes plan over
lengthy time Horizons grasp new Concepts
rapidly or Reason with abstractions
Summerfield cites three lines of
argument against the temptation to
constrain AI systems with principles
from biology firstly building an AI is a
general problem so it needs a general
solution
every constraint that AI designer
relaxes makes the system more attuned to
a broad class of problems and so the
most successful AI systems are those
which leverage computation this is
exemplified by the success of deepminds
alphago zero Alpha zero and mu zero
which is a deliberate attempt to seek to
minimize the extent to which AI
achievements are kick-started by
built-in human understanding and just a
little note from me ironically now we're
going in the opposite direction with
chat GPT the importance of human
fine-tuning and knowledge is kind of
swinging back but anyway
the second line of argument is that
humans might not be intelligent in the
first place
it's argued that the goal of AI cannot
just be to copy humans as this will lead
to systems that display the same vices
and limitations therefore AI researchers
should strive to build something that
can reason more powerfully and display
more brilliant inventiveness
so I wonder whether you would say chat
gbt is more powerful and more inventive
maybe it's truncated by the fine tuning
that we've applied to it
uh the third line of argument is that if
AI researchers do draw upon intuitions
from Psychology and Neuroscience When
developing AI can they be sure that any
knowledge built in is actually useful
current Neuroscience might not be quite
up to the job of explaining how brains
actually work
and the elaborate theories that are
built about neural computation could
just be wider the Mark or just plain
wrong
a clear example of what Sutton warned
against Summerfield said that we've
already seen that systems
neuroscientists have mostly avoided
searching for General theories
preferring instead to taxonomize
computational processes in a way which
abstracts over the wet and messy detail
of human function
this suspicion was not helped by Elon
Musk the founder of openai who when
recruiting for researchers to work on
his brain computer image project
neurolink he made it clear that quote no
prior experience in Neuroscience is
necessary we'll teach you everything you
need to know
remarkable isn't it
the conclusion is that the most
effective way to build AI is to reach
for the computational sky and build ever
larger models on ever faster computers
and this is the path that deepmind had
followed with Alpha zero go and Alpha
zero and mu zero and it's been
incredibly successful Moore's Law the
principle that the power of computation
should double every year is still alive
and kicking and this means that the
resources available to researchers
continues to grow and grow in the end
the case for General methods which
leverage computation according to Chris
is the most effective this is the lesson
that's been learned from 70 years of AI
research and it's the path that AI
researchers should continue to follow if
they want to make genuine progress
anyway that was an excerpt from chapter
two of Chris's book just to remind you
again it's
an amazing book it honestly it's an
amazing book please buy it the link is
in the video description and I had a
great deal of fun driving up to Oxford
to chat with Chris a couple of weeks ago
and if you're watching on YouTube with I
also had a cameraman so we've got lots
of cool camera angles and walk
walkie-talkie type shots so um anyway
without any further delay I give you
Professor Christopher Summerfield hi I'm
Chris Summerfield
um I'm a professor of cognitive
neuroscience at the University of Oxford
I'm also a fellow at wadham College
which is where we are now and I also am
a research scientist at deepmind in
London what inspired you to be a
professor of cognitive neuroscience
uh well I um I'm a psychologist by
training so I've studied for many years
uh how memory and attention and control
and language work in uh in the human
brain if you want to study the human
brain then there's sort of three
approaches that you can take so one is
you can study human behavior the other
is that you can try and measure brain
activity and the last is that you can
try and build mathematical models of how
it all fits together and cognitive
Neuroscience is a field which kind of
combines all of those three elements and
you that's that's where my work has
ended up I really really enjoy putting
all that that information together
wonderful I spoke to Murray Shanahan
recently and and um he really believes
that an intersectional approach is is
useful
um so he's bringing in a lot of ideas
from philosophy and of course you know
cognitive robotics as well as Ai and
machine learning so I I think it's
really interesting having that diversity
but let's launch straight into your book
I mean just anecdotally as well I want
to let you know that it is the best book
on AI I've ever read I've I've been
glued to it for the last four days I
haven't been able to tear myself away
from it and just making notes every two
seconds and it's a really wonderful book
so thank you so much for writing it it's
very kind thank you so um let's talk
about plausibility versus understanding
so large language models have been
criticized as not representing a true
understanding of the world that we live
in and they're said to produce plausible
outfits given the prompt now what does
it mean to understand something
yeah so you probably want a philosopher
to answer this question so actually the
nature of understanding has been given
much more consideration in philosophy
than it has in cognitive science I
always think it's really surprising that
in Psychology and Neuroscience we have
whole fields that are dedicated to
understanding really difficult Concepts
like Consciousness we don't actually
really have a subfield within psychology
that is the psychology of understanding
what does it mean but if we look at the
sort of the intersection between
philosophy and cognitive science
understanding is usually linked to the
notion of having a a mental model which
can be used for complex inference so the
idea is that we biological agents or
artificial agents as we go about the
world we form a model of how the world
Works usually a causal model an
understanding of how variables causally
interact and the understanding arises
when we're able to leverage that model
typically to make new predictions or to
understand complex phenomena so in the
context of large language models what do
people mean well I think what they mean
is that you know if you ask a model like
chat gbt to give you information factual
information about a topic in biology
it will you know usually produce
something which approximates what you
find on Wikipedia but it doesn't
typically in most cases have the ability
to leverage its understanding to draw
new inferences right so it can't
um for the most part it can't explicitly
reason over the information that it has
in memory now there are tricks that can
help language models do that so you're
probably aware of Chain of Thought
prompting which you know kind of
encourages language models to to do
something that looks a bit more like
their you know kind of reasoning in a
way which would reflect understanding
but I think you know our understand our
understanding of how to do this is very
much in its infancy at the moment
interesting yeah and because people have
spoken about whether language models
have
um tensionality Consciousness all sorts
of esoteric Concepts but they do appear
to have emergent reasoning and with
knowledge of course you know there's the
epistemic version which is a Justified
true belief but there's also the
ontological version and I'm interested
did in this notion of whether there can
be a platonic one true understanding of
the world we live in law if you're at a
lower resolution there might be
ambiguous and inconsistent
understandings almost like the Blind Men
and the Elephant yeah well this is a
question which is really close to my
heart I mean I think that in computer
science today
um you know probably because computer
scientists are all trained in they're
formally trained in maths and statistics
and physics and and of course in
Computing itself or in coding languages
there is a real desire to see language
as a codification of the reality of the
world and you know this is a tradition
in linguistics which goes back to
Chomsky you know kind of the role of
language is to disclose the fundamental
underlying reality that we all
experience and to share it with each
other right
but there's another view of language
which is that language is a much more
social process by which we construct
shared meaning between conversation
partners and that shared meaning need
not be unified in any you know so Global
sense it doesn't have to point to a
single unified reality it can actually
be quite decentralized quite local
and you know I think that's what you're
referring to and the challenge is there
you know if we have these plurality of
meanings for different concepts but in
different topics then whose reality
should language models Express and I
think this is an unsolved question it's
really a philosopher it's a question for
people working in ethics and safety as
much as people working actually at the
front end of you know
language modeling yeah and it gets to
the heart of what soul was saying about
this kind of dichotomy between ontology
and and epistemic knowledge we spoke
with um Chomsky and um you know he even
he said as a rationalist nativist that
there's still a large Divergence between
the kind of epistemic reality encoded in
our language and the ontological reality
in the real world I think he thinks that
um there's a huge gap between the
universe as it is and and our
understanding of it they calls it the
ghost of the machine
yeah well I mean you know I'm not a I'm
not a linguist
um or a philosopher but
um I I think I recognize the enormous
challenge particularly when we think
about important topics like alignment
and especially for language models the
enormous challenge of thinking about to
whom we align our language models and
you know of course if there is a single
underlying reality then we just have to
align our language models with that and
then we're done right but I don't think
it's quite so simple and I think it's a
really incumbent particularly given
um the you know the demographic of
machine learning researchers who you
know tend to be tend to come from more
privileged backgrounds tend to be
Western actually you know kind of in
they tend to be men they tend to be
white
um I think it's really incumbent on us
to to to be careful not to to think that
there is one true reality which is the
things that that we learned in school
and that that's what we should put into
our language models really really
interesting and we'll get to the
intelligence stuff in a minute because
you spoke about how we designed the test
to be a reflection of ourselves
um okay let's let's go on to creativity
because this is something that really
interests me now um after Lisa doll's
match uh he expressed this sentiment and
you wrote about this in in your book he
said that he thought alphago was based
on probability calculations and it was
merely a machine but when he saw this
move he changed his mind alphago was
creative the move was really creative
and beautiful he said it really made him
think about it in a new light now what
is creativity and does it does it need
what we call agency
what will creativity is probably in the
eyes of the beholder
um in that case I think what Lisa doll
was referring to was the fact that you
know kind of the the policy the the
actions that um Alpha go in that setting
was able to produce were not only you
know they were out of not not only out
of distribution for a normal go player
but they're out of distribution for an
expert like himself right and of course
it is a property of
um generativity that you know what what
we assess as good generativity is that
we're able to generate things that are
new but which are you know kind of also
sort of plausible and interesting and
reflective of you know kind of they they
don't violate basic preconceptions about
how the world works but yet they do
something that no one has ever done
before and that's true for human
creativity right when we think about uh
you know kind of in the Arts or you know
if you if you are composing a new piece
of music there are certain you know
there are there are guard rails within
which you you compose your music you
don't just make random sounds but at the
same time you also don't just copy what
other people have done and
so is agency necessary for creativity
well I mean you know I think that what
we've seen recently with the large
um the success of large generative
models implies that it's not
so for the most part you know kind of
obviously those models may be fine-tuned
with reinforcement learning but for the
most part they're just trained on you
know kind of large volumes of data which
are then you know they are produced
they're generated in a predictive
fashion
and sometimes the outcomes are really
they appear to me at least to be pretty
creative
so interesting
um one one element of it and we'll talk
about the abstraction topology space
later but it's a bit like with free will
it wouldn't really be free will if it
was a random number generator so it
needs to fall on on the manifold of of
let's say the abstractions which you
know which can occur which are grounded
to the world that we live in but even
then
gpt3 it's a bit like a chicken and an
egg problem so is it creative on its own
or is it creative in tandem with human
prompting
well I mean
I I think that that question is a
question of taste right I mean you know
if you think of human creativity you
know there's nothing new Under the Sun
right so if I generate if I make a
beautiful new painting and everyone
admires it well to what extent am I
simply an inheritor of artistic
Traditions or ideas that I have I have
seen
I think you know exactly the same
framework is how we should think about
language models right so they are
trained on they're trained they're
pre-trained on large volumes of data
they're often then fine-tuned on much
more specific data or perhaps with
reinforcement learning or an equivalent
method and so of course
what they are capable of doing is a
product of what they have experienced
just like it is for us
okay and and in your book you sketched
out
various different forms of AI that are
truncated in different ways because
there's this kind of um it's a bit like
good heart's law it's a bit like um what
Sarah hooker calls the hardware Lottery
which is this kind of determinism of the
potential of a system based on the
hardware and kind of philosophical
design decisions that you make you gave
the example in classical psychology
where human abstractions are are used to
build the models
um a similar form of constraining is is
things like inductive priors or whether
we buy some thinking or or knowing and
also whether we train on human data and
the extent to which it's aligned and
human compatible and so on so there are
so many trade-offs on on that Spectrum
um give me some thought
that's a very broad question I mean I
think you know maybe what you're
alluding to is a point that I I tried to
make throughout the book which is that
um when we're thinking about how we
should build AI or indeed you know how
we should model
um human uh brain processes which is my
you know primary expertise then you know
we really need to think about what the
nature of the problem is what the nature
of the world is so you know kind of in
cognitive science and in Neuroscience
people have long understood that in
order to understand you know kind of how
neurons are functioning or brain areas
interact or why people produce certain
Behavior behave in certain ways or
produce you know certain patterns of
outputs
we need to start by thinking about what
computational problem the brain is
trying to solve right so what is the
world like such that it requires this
Behavior or this neural activity
and I think you know kind of it's often
overlooked in AI research that exactly
the same
framework can be really useful right we
need to begin by thinking about what the
system is actually there for in the
first place
and the constraints so you talked about
you know kind of inductive biases or you
know kind of whether we train with human
data or with self-play whether we try to
sort of explicitly model cognition or
just you know let it emerge
the answers to What's going to work best
is going to depend on the nature of the
problem and machine learning as you will
know better than me is a very broad
Church you know kind of some of our
applications are quite narrow and
targeted right if I want to build a
self-driving car then I need it to do
certain things you know I don't need it
to be able to complete the crossword for
me and
I think you know often in machine
learning we talk about Solutions without
actually talking about what the problem
is and you know in the book I refer to
this this thing which is you know I
think I call it the meta problem which
is like you know kind of what is the
thing that we ultimately actually want
the AI to do
and
I I'm sure many people do have their own
answers to that question but I don't
think we have a consensus and I think
even you know kind of within the major
research companies there is you know
kind of there isn't one sort of single
answer to that question
yeah what what it what interests me
about chat GPT is that it's the first
instance of an AI which has reached the
masses it's in the public Consciousness
and it's the first real example of a
meta AI I mean it's still constrained in
the modality and the interface and so on
although it's a very human aligned
interface it's very interesting and you
can do almost anything with it swiss
cheese problem permitting maybe we can
bring that in but um so so it is it is a
meta problem uh solver
well I don't know if it solves The Meta
problem I think the the problem well
first of all let's let's just make sure
we're clear about what we're talking
about so
um it is definitely true that chat GPT
is the first instance of a language
model which has been released into the
wild and is being used by thousands
probably Millions now of people
um which is very impressive that's not
to say that it's the first machine
learning technology which impacts our
lives right so our lives are subtly and
imperceptibly influenced by Machine
learning at every moment right every
time you look at your phone or go on
Facebook or
um you know kind of even or make
consumer decisions or whatever these
there is
um these are influenced by AI just
perhaps in ways which are not
immediately so transparent so
charity beauty is special because it it
what it does is it it brings into it
brings the experience of interacting
with an agent that is non-human in
natural language it brings that
experience to the general population in
a way which hasn't happened before
but I think the the mere existence of
successful language models doesn't
really answer the question of what
they're for right
so let me give you some examples so chat
GPT is a is a prompt and response model
right so what that means is that you ask
it a question it gives you an answer
so it doesn't do what you and I might do
what we are doing in this conversation
which is to you know kind of to to share
information two ways right so I'm
learning from your questions as
hopefully you're learning from my
answers it doesn't do what people do in
normal conversation which is that they
reciprocate right so chap GPD never asks
you anything back
the uses of conversation it's very good
if you want to ask chat GPD for
information it's quite happy to provide
it but it doesn't do the sorts of things
that we naturally do in conversation
um when you know kind of we try to
establish
um what's the best course of action to
take
or we seek Mutual reassurance or we try
to clarify our own thinking on topics
that don't have a right and the wrong
answer can't do any of these things
most of what we use natural language for
are actually exactly those things if you
think of the conversations that you have
with friends or Partners most of them
don't consist of you going and asking
for a detailed explanation of what
happened in the War of the Roses but
that's what people use to actually be or
asking them to compose a you know a
funny poem in the style of x
but that's mostly what people use to
actually Beauty for so I would slightly
push back on that in the sense that I
mean first of all from an intelligence
point of view and I agree with Chalet
that it's task acquisition efficiency
and with um in context learning you can
apparently make it do almost anything so
I do see it as a bit of a blank slate
and and also you can even prompt it to
do some of the things that you were just
speaking about in terms of getting
advice about things or having a
conversation and um and also we'll talk
about Peter's Triad and you know the um
the the most important element of the
Triad which is the third one the the
abstract symbolic
component which is embedded in our
language so it's it's the first example
of an AI which apparently
um can recognize abstract Concepts like
Christmas
well so I mean clearly you're right that
in context learning is really powerful
right and the I think the the big the
big revelation of the last few years has
been that
um in context learning with Transformers
is so and and at scale is sufficient to
allow
um emergent meta learning right so
that's really what that's you know we we
previously have been able to to show
that you know by carefully crafting
a meta training curriculum or a meta
training sequence
um models can learn to perform new tasks
that fall broadly within this
distribution the surprise is that just
by training on large sizes of the
internet you can get something that
approximates that of course you know
touch EBT is not just a generative model
it's trained with reinforcement learning
from Human feedback right so it's
changed from Human preferences as well
so in that sense you know you're right
that we don't know what the limits of
this approach are and maybe the limits
are you know maybe there are many many
things that you can do with this but you
know kind of once again that's a
statement about the solution not about
the problem right
my my point is that we need to think
more about what the problem is about
what we want AI to do and you know that
question I think that that question is
coming into focus more
but it is inextricably entangled with
questions of you know kind of
um the ethics and safety of AI systems
of the the interface between
the social sciences and you know
computer science and technology right
you know what what role should these
models have in our society what role do
we want them to play
and what do we want to use them for
and I one of the points that I try and
make in the book is that we need better
answers to those questions yes and I'm
speaking with Luciano for really later
and he's got an um a wonderful
philosophy of information where I mean
similar to Heidegger actually kind of
sees it as
um a kind of layer between us and
ontological reality and and that kind of
um derangement goes in both directions
it kind of it changes us at a very
visceral level
um but anyway I wanted to talk about
whether Neuroscience can impart useful
knowledge to Ai and we can broaden out
to things like Linguistics and
psychology a lot of folks deride
Linguistics there was that famous quote
about every time I fire a linguist the
NLP accuracy goes up and and you wrote a
quote actually from Elon Musk good old
Elon Musk no prior experience in
Neuroscience is necessary we will teach
you everything you need to know now that
is is that just arrogance
well I think there is an element of
hubris in contemporary machine learning
and AI research I think there is a sense
that you know kind of the
the structured theories which exist in
linguistics and in cognitive science and
in education research and in in the
social sciences in economics that these
are sort of you know kind of these are
these are play things
and that actually we can sort of do
without that knowledge and you know we
can just use large-scale function
approximation to solve problems
um
on the one hand you know kind of there
are instances where that is almost
certainly true right you know it's
certainly true that
um the models that we have built
especially in the social sciences don't
have very good predictive validity so
economists aren't all that good at
predicting what you know kind of
prevention financial markets will
actually do behavioral scientists aren't
actually all that good at predicting how
humans will behave
um and it's true that we can use machine
learning to make more accurate
predictions and I think that's kind of
what you know that that that has driven
a a kind of belief in some corners of
computer science that
past theorizing in these fields is sort
of not all that important
but you know I think that sort of
overlooks the fact that when we build
models you know we build models for
multiple reasons especially we build
models both for prediction not not only
for prediction but also for explanation
and that the explanatory role of models
in understanding a problem
is you know kind of it's it's a really
huge part of what is contributed by all
of you know fields in the social and
life sciences
and
I think you know that knowledge can be
incredibly useful and it can be
incredibly useful especially when it
comes to something like deployment right
so you know let me give you an example
if you wanted to use an AI system to for
example a language model to teach
someone how to do something then you
might say oh okay we can just sort of
you know do without you know maybe we
can just learn an optimal curriculum
from first principles using machine
learning but then you know if human
students learn in sort of idiosyncratic
ways or you know maybe there are aspects
of their learning which are you know
kind of haven't even entered the machine
learning researchers Consciousness like
you know maybe you need to motivate them
appropriately or you know kind of maybe
you need to account for their
aspirations or you know kind of their
cultural context then if you don't know
these things then you're probably not
going to succeed interesting could you
bring Rich Sutton into this and maybe we
can also talk about the neats and the
scruffies and um so that there's there's
this notion from Rich Sutton that the
world is a very complex place and and
you said in your book that you know a
lot of the the research in Neuroscience
is a bit like the blind man and the
Elephant they want to have a model with
explanatory power so um the Temptation
was just to kind of work on on something
in isolation and and ignore the messy
reality and Rich Sutton said of course
just just stop Building Things by hand
we need to embrace the complexity lots
of compute and so on so um and and that
leads us on to the neats and the
scruffies I think you know somewhat
analogously so um are you a nature as
graphic look at my jumper
could you introduce it
um yeah I mean I think I'm probably a
scruffy
um both you know sartorially and
intellectually
um yeah I mean I you know obviously
there is no there is no exact mapping
from the the original the notion of
needs and scruffy's dates back to the
60s and 70s and originally described you
know kind of
symbolic AI researchers who were
primarily focused on on you know
building logic systems versus building
you know kind of language systems or
their equivalents right you know did you
need to sort of solve a real world
problem and just Tinker till you got it
right or did you need to start from you
know kind of let's reduce thinking down
to three logical principles and build
everything back up from there right and
those were the the scruffies and the
meats respectively and today
you know what do we have well you know
kind of I think today what we have is
um it's it's not it's not an exact
mapping but we have people who you know
kind of want to eliminate the the messy
reality of the human world from machine
learning research you know by saying
okay you know let's let's try to have as
little human
um as little knowledge of human uh brain
function in rml systems let's try and
have as little human data in our in our
ml systems as possible
and those people are maybe contrasted
with
um you know another group who say well
you know actually we just gotta you know
we really just got to learn from you
know and from Human data and you know
the language modeling that we're seeing
you know is obviously more firmly in the
latter camp
Ridge Sutton I mean maybe I could just
say you know I think
in Rich Sutton in about three years ago
he wrote this incredibly famous blog
post called The Bitter lesson which he
articulated the point of view that you
you just summarized so he said you know
we should forget about
um you know kind of Knowledge from
psychology or Linguistics and or
cognitive science and we should just
build big powerful systems with lots of
compute and
you know I think you know he was both
right and wrong
I think the success of large models
with relatively undifferentiated
um structure architecture
suggests that you know maybe he was
broadly right about the fact that we
just need to build big models
but I think what he was wrong about was
the role of human data
and I think that what you know you
reference to gbt so chat gbt is of
course I mean of course it's you know
it's trained on the whole of the
internet
um approximately but it's fine-tuned
with lots and lots of
um performance feedback from uh human
raters right for human evaluators
so it's success hinges very much upon
human preferences
and I think that was unforeseen in that
blog post
um and I think you know it will be
defining for AI research going forward
that if we want to build systems that
people actually want to use and find
useful then we need to ground their
performance ground their training in
human learning human outcomes human
beliefs human preferences because
otherwise they're just not going to be
all that useful
okay but um folks talk about you know
super intelligence intelligence
explosion the really interesting thing
about Alpha zero was its superhuman
performance and I don't just mean you
know one human I mean Humanity it was
just on another level
and when we constrain with human data my
intuition is it's a good thing and a bad
thing my intuition is that it will no
longer transgress human capability but
it will be more human aligned more human
compatible
yeah I'm I'm not sure I entirely agree
with that right so obviously you're
right that you know I'll forget what was
exciting about alphago was that
precisely that it
um it was able to to beat every human on
the planet at a game which humans had
devised and spent some human spend a lot
of time trying to perfect their play on
um but of course you know go
go is not like the world and the world
is not like go right so go is a it's a
deterministic game it's a game of finite
information it's a zero-sum game the
world does not have those properties for
the most part
go is Guided by a set of like
um of of
um of rules which are you're fully
deterministic
the world does not revolve around
deterministic rules and what that means
is that for the most part the world
doesn't exhibit the systematicity
that logical or mathematical systems
exhibit at least not at the level of
that we understand it undoubtedly it's
systematic at the level of particles or
Quantum phenomena it obeys the laws of
physics but not at the level that we
understand it
and so what that means is that systems
which you know use self-play to try to
come up with you know policies which are
out of the human distribution
maybe they're useful for a a relatively
small set of problems in which you can
in which you can systematize the world
in which human human preferences really
don't come into it
um
but I think for the majority of
applications in which we actually would
find AI to be useful being out of human
distribution at either end is going to
be worse than useless
so it's no good you know if you're a if
you're a teacher
um in a primary school and you know a
student asks you you know what's the
answer to you know why is the sky is
blue why is the sky blue and you give an
answer which you know kind of is a
degree level physics you know kind of
response
then you haven't learned in it the
student hasn't learned anything that's
not what's required
so we need our systems to be to
understand what humans want and to be
tailored to those beliefs and
preferences
yeah I love the point discussing the
degree to which go and the real world
may be analogous and I think when you
when you spoke of systematicity I think
you mean it in a kind of photo volition
kind of kind of way
um and indeed the world is not
deterministic and we can get onto the
probabilistic stuff later but
um Sutton and hutter do believe
that the world can be represented with a
markup decision process and of course
you have an agent you have affordances
you have action and so on so so that in
some sense they they do believe that
their approaches could work in the real
world yeah that's that's the hypothesis
that they call the the reward is enough
hypothesis yeah yeah so um I was going
to go there later but we're there now
yeah why don't you introduce it sure
well I mean I guess you know a starting
point for this debate is is the mdp
itself right so mdp micro decision
process I mean incredibly useful tool
for you know machine learning for
control and laterally you know
reinforcement learning
um and of course it's the very framework
we were just talking about alphago it's
the very framework that allowed you know
kind of go to be solved amongst many
other exciting problems of a similar
nature
but I think your question is you know
can we model the world with that
framework and you know undoubtedly you
know from a purely theoretical
standpoint the answer is is yes we could
but would it actually be useful to do so
well let's think about what happens what
do you actually do if you are a machine
learning researcher in RL you know let's
say you want your agent to solve a video
game of some sorts right a standard
application well so you first of all
have to specify an objective for the
agent so well that's easy if you're in a
video game because you can say okay well
each video game has a goal which is to
maximize your score without you know
losing lives right great so we can write
that down as the reward that's the r in
the markup decision process
um and we can we can train our agent to
maximize that but what what's the
equivalent in the real world
so in the real world you know kind of
when you take actions we might consider
them to be rewarding or not as the case
may be but there isn't a sort of magical
you know process in the sky that kind of
administers rewards to us on the basis
of our actions it's not like oh I ate an
apple and I got 10 points for that
fact in the real world
observations and rewards are the same
thing so rewards are observations and
observations are Rewards
and what this means is that you know
kind of the the mdp
um process for modeling or the mdp
approach for modeling the real world is
fundamentally at odds with actually how
biology works
so rewards are not extrinsic they're not
administered by the machine learning
researcher they are intrinsic when we
talk about reward you know the hedonic
experience of eating an apple
that's an experience which is intrinsic
it's generated by the agent itself
now if you have agents that can generate
their own rewards then suddenly you're
in a completely different computational
landscape because the first thing that
could happen if you give the agent full
Liberty to generate its own rewards is
that it can just say oh just find
everything rewarding and then it's
instantly maximized its reward so we
don't do that
presumably because we're under another
constraint which is that we need to
survive and reproduce but that survival
and reproduction constraint is just not
there in reinforcement learning we're
not optimizing for that we're optimizing
for this weird proxy which is reward
and so if you think about it just finish
if you think about it you know let's try
and think what alphago would be in the
real world right you know what's you
know what's the kind of or Alpha zero
right you know what what is what is
World zero right what would it look like
well what you would need is you'd need a
really patient machine learning
researcher to come along and annotate
every single action that every single
person might take with a score and that
score would be need to be exactly what
you would you know what would be
required for you know whatever we deem
to be you know intelligent Behavior
so who's going to do that not me yeah so
we need the the big man in in the sky to
um you know ordain the rewards but
there's a there's a few kind of areas to
explore with the reward hypothesis
um from the angle of behaviorism
um from the angle of um uh intelligence
from the behaviorism angle
you had a wonderful story in your book
about the monkey and
um how it how it managed to get the
banana and the behaviorists of course
think that there's just a very
um simple relationship between stimulus
and response and in this experiment the
monkey just kind of sat in the thought
for a while and had a flash of
inspiration uh it was thinking right and
um you know naively I I think of reward
as being a weird kind of inverse
behaviorism you know this this kind of
focus on on the um uh the output signal
itself that was the the third thing um
teleology so
um you were speaking in the book a
little bit about how Advocates of
reinforcement learning they they they
see affordances and actions as kind of
leading to a to a form of goal-directed
behavior and I was kind of
um Bridging the Gap between simple gold
directed behavior and rewards and
teleology and in itself so what is our
purpose and I think folks in
reinforcement learning see this kind of
natural emergence hierarchy so if only
we can place one reward at the top then
we get this emergent intelligence we get
intrinsic motivation we get this kind of
hierarchy of sub-rewards and so on but
there seems to me to be a kind of
fundamental chicken and egg problem
there
yeah I mean I
I'm not sure I entirely followed your
question but let me try and pick up on a
few things so first of all yeah I think
you're absolutely right that you know
kind of at the heart of the reward is
enough hypothesis is the idea that you
know kind of there there exists
somewhere a very simple set of
principles which we could write down
which would Define how rewarding things
should or should not be right so you
know maybe we could say everything
reduces to Information Gain or
everything reduces to empowerment or to
you know maximization of one one
quantity or another there are many
different minimization of cognitive
dissonance
and you know there is a hope that there
is a single principle that we can
um we can adopt
um
so yeah um I was looking at the reward
hypothesis from the angle of
um teleology so you know the the the you
know we we have I'm not even sure if you
if it's reducible but we have this
notion of purpose
and uh cyberneticists and people like
cell think that it kind of emerges from
biology
and um so there's this kind of question
of where does it come from and what is
it and
I guess my criticism of reinforcement
learning is it it appears as if we are
reducing that purpose or that end goal
into one property
so so there's that
um I'm naturally cynical about well not
cynical skeptical of behaviorism because
I see it as a dominating Paradigm in how
we measure intelligence
um most of our tests are that of
behavior in our metrics and so on and I
haven't I don't completely understand
this but it seems to me like
um reward maximization is a form of a
weird form of behaviorism which means
that it's almost like we're not looking
at the mechanism we're just looking at
the action so is it fair to say the
action is the other side of the coin of
behavior in some way
okay let me see if I can understand or
unpack your question I'm kind of
thinking out loud here a little bit so
sure are we actually recording there
even on the Sony A1 yeah oh okay well
we'll use that though too yeah Okay cool
so
the the term behaviorism refers to a
movement that dominated psychology
throughout the early part of the 20th
century associated with figures like
Watson and Skinner
and it was
um founded on the idea that to
understand the human mind you really
have to understand first how humans
behave or understand solely how humans
behave and also true for Animals as well
so the idea was that
we can explain
how we can explain human motivation
human behavior exclusively through the
links between stimulation and response
the forming forming of associations
between stimulus and response
and so
um behaviorism
um its sidesteps questions around how
cognition is structured right so it
overlooks you know what what are the
role of our multiple memory systems it's
sort of it doesn't ask questions about
how we attend to the world you know
attention psychological construct
described since the 19th century of it
completely overlooks or or you know kind
of reduces it to a very simple notion of
salience
um it doesn't really talk about language
or it doesn't really give explanations
for how we learn language or at least
not plausible explanations because
everything is a chain of associations
then you know it assumes that we can we
learn all Language by just forming links
between adjacent words
which then doesn't explain you mentioned
Chomsky earlier doesn't explain the the
infinite generativity of language so
that's what behaviorism is and
reinforcement learning
as a movement within machine learning
grew out of
um the study the behaviorist study of
animal learning
um so the original
um the original formulation for example
of TD learning
um by Saturn nambato
um in the in the 80s
um was it was originally formulated to
try to understand the stimulus response
behavior of experimental animals
um so you know kind of the its adequacy
as a theory of intelligence has been
under debate in Psychology and in
machine learning for you know the best
part of a hundred years right and I
think your critique is that
um reinforcement learning or or you know
the the overall behaviorist approach
assumes that there is some specific set
of behaviors which are optimal in the
world given a reward function which is
externally specified which in the lab is
like you know does the experimental
animal get you know peanuts for or juice
for making this choice or that choice
and in the world might be you know do we
receive reward for you know kind of
saying this thing or doing this thing
and you know I share your skepticism
about
that approach and I think that you know
it doesn't mean that reinforcement
learning as a tool is not an absolutely
fundamental part of how biological
agents learn and it doesn't mean that it
shouldn't be a fundamental part of how
artificial systems learn
but it's not all there is to the story
and in particular you know we need
answers to the question of how
intelligent systems generate their own
purpose right so I think you know
there's a very nice linking back to
alignment again it's a really nice way
of thinking about the distinction
between narrow and in general
intelligence which I cite in the book
which is you know we can think of a
narrow
intelligence as a system which is given
task and executes it very well and we
can think of a general intelligence as
one that dreams up the task in the first
place
and so you know kind of that sense of
purpose like what am I supposed to be
doing and why
that's the the really hard Challenge and
as we were discussing earlier it's
really remains a largely unsolved
challenge remains an unsolved challenge
partly because humans haven't worked out
what they want AI systems for
but it's also because you know even if
you take our most powerful you know kind
of large generative models or our best
RL systems They Don't Really generate
their own they don't they don't generate
their own goals like humans do they
don't set themselves objective
objectives and then seek to satisfy them
what they do is they they do what you
know what they're trained to do right
so um a lot of this gets back to how the
lens kind of truncates our frame of
reference I mean even in this discussion
with behaviorism it's similar to this
concept of a white box and a black box
or behavior and mechanism and um uh when
I was speaking with Chalmers who he
would talk about function and Dynamics
and the the subjective experience you
know so there's all of these different
kind of um uh filters that we use that
that exclude parts of the truth a bit
like the blind man and the Elephant but
um similarly good heart's law so um it's
a well-known problem in in machine
learning and it's related to what you
said a fundamental indeterminacy
principle when the measure becomes a
Target it ceases to be a good measure so
um you said even as a field if we were
to agree on a definitive set of tests
for General AI researchers would
immediately Focus their energies on
solving those specific problems so
another example of this cone of
attention rather than building agents
whose generality extends further to
open-ended real world settings where we
hope AGI May 1B May one day be deployed
so this gets us into the whole
benchmarks thing what are your thoughts
about that yeah
so I I guess that one way to tackle this
question is to think about
what what is the role of optimization in
biological systems you know are we sort
of gradually optimized towards some
objective is that a good description of
our learning and in some ways maybe it
is right so you know clearly over the
course of development we start off
fairly random and our Behavior becomes
fairly structured over the course of
development both you know kind of
development and learning right so you
know even in adulthood we can learn new
things hopefully
um so
it does seem like that might be a
plausible model and of course that's
been picked up recently by
neuroscientists who view tools from
machine learning like convolutional
neural networks to try and understand
you know kind of object recognition in
humans for example
on the one hand there is a there's a
great deal of excitement around the idea
that we can understand human Learning
and Development through the lens of
optimization
but on the other hand
um we we I think the Paradigm in which
that we use the Paradigm that we use for
machine learning is fundamentally
unsuited to capturing the nature of the
problem that biological agents face in
the natural world and that is because
you know if you think about it the the
basic premise in which you know deep
learning is founded is that you know if
you have a large and diverse training
set and you sample IID from that
training set then ultimately your system
is going to be able to encode a
distribution which will allow it to you
know interpolate or extrapolate a small
small extrapolation
um to new previously unencountered test
examples right
but in the natural world you know we
don't live forever
and there is no way given the
um the way in which the natural world is
is structured that we live in a a Locale
which is very different from other
places you know we meet people who are
very different from other people we
study things that are very different
from other topics that we might
encounter we only get a tiny tiny slice
of the distribution that is natural life
and so using the principle that we we
just sort of you know kind of get as
much training as possible and as much
diversity and experience as possible and
use that to generalize that's just it's
just not feasible when you only live for
four score years and ten if you're lucky
and so
humans I think have learned or have
evolved very different ways of learning
that are not about sort of gradient
descent towards one you know sort of
perfect version of themselves but rather
what we do is we're constantly adapting
to our local circumstances we're
constantly we're constantly forming new
models of the world not not just
building one model of the world we're
constantly forming and reforming our
models of the world using composition
which perhaps we can talk about in a
minute yes I'd love to get on to maybe
we should do intelligence then we'll get
into conversationality but um yeah so
you delivered a wonderful anecdote in
your book about Von Neumann and there's
wit and I could tell that you too Chris
are off the charts on on the
intelligence scale just based on the
high resolution and and sometimes
esoteric language that that you used
um but they shouldn't necessarily mean
that that you're intelligent because a
book is crystallized I have an intuition
that there's something about the kind of
information conversion efficiency that
that tells us about intelligence but um
I must say actually I was reaching for
the dictionary quite often and um I
couldn't decide whether whether the word
desiderata is gratuitous or delicious I
do love them
I do love that word but I know Orwell
would um have something to say about
having read his essay politics and the
English language but anyway
um you said the question of whether
there is one intelligence uh or many has
been the subject of much research and
debate among cognitive scientists you
told the story of spearman's G factor
and the more heterogeneous version from
uh Gardner who like Minsky and how you
were just alluding to thinks there's a
society of of mind
um so
um I'm actually interested in this idea
of Elizabeth spelkey's work at Harvard
she talks about core cognitive priors
like you know a agentiveness and spatial
temporal reasoning and and so on and and
maybe within those those prior there's
there's some degree of generality
um but um you also said that the
intelligence tests were designed to make
westerners look the smartest of them all
and of course there's the Bostrom Fiasco
recently I mean Could you um talk a
little bit about that
yeah I mean so intelligence testing has
a very checkered history as I'm sure you
know
um you know the earliest intelligence
tests were went you know sort of hand in
hand with attempts to exclude
marginalized groups from various roles
in society
um and you know kind of whilst today the
study or the measurement of the human
mind is a sort of a slightly more
reputable
Endeavor it's still I think you know
really fraught with political challenges
not least because you know ultimately if
you wish to to specify if you wish to
build an intelligence test just like you
know we were discussing in the context
of AI what is AI for what does it mean
for an AI to be intelligence intelligent
if you want to build an intelligence
test for humans you need to start with
some preconception about what that
intelligence entails
so in other words there's a circularity
in the building of intelligence tests in
the you know the way we build them
presupposes what we think intelligence
is but yet the test itself is purporting
to measure that very intelligence
so what in what are we supposed to
ground our Notions of human intelligence
and this is where you know kind of I
think that the opportunity for bias and
discrimination have come in in the sense
that you know Western
[Music]
um uh Western educated
um probably quite privileged researchers
in you know academic institutions have
taken it upon themselves to Define what
intelligence is and by definition by the
way they have defined it that means that
groups that are culturally or socially
different from them are much like much
less likely to meet up to the standard
that they have set and you can see this
and you know it's still a standard
feature of many intelligence tests to
include
um you know vocabulary
um as a measure of intelligence of
course you know how big your vocabulary
is has to do with you know where you
went to school and you know how much
opportunity you've had to read lots of
books and you know taught the meaning of
complex Concepts which is completely
different from the intelligence that you
need to navigate in the Sahara Desert or
you know make medicines from local
plants or even you know to organize your
Society in a you know where whether
you're in you know kind of the Kalahari
Desert or or here in Oxford
wonderful now um we're a little bit
short on time so let's talk about
thinking versus knowing and um
we can we can sketch out the Divergence
and AI research actually with Minsky and
rosenblatts they both went to the to the
Bronx um Academy didn't they in the
1940s and then they went off on very
different trajectories one thinking one
knowing and you can bring that in but I
wanted to talk about compositionality
because when I speak with go5 folks and
and I love go five folks so good friends
of many of them and um the I think the
most persuasive argument they have is
are these kind of um volition style
systematicity compositionality type
arguments so um you spoke about this on
page 101 and uh so on the thinking side
you said
um you know symbolic approaches which
allow for Limitless productivity from
limited mental Primitives these complex
Concepts can be composed from simpler
building blocks using a set of formal
rules it's a powerful principle that can
endow computation with great versatility
flexibility expressiveness and of course
it led to ideas like the language of
thought and indeed chomsky's innate
mental grammar so on the thinking side
of the of the balance that's very
powerful sure yeah absolutely so
obviously this debate you know has 70
years of History
um you know and and we won't be able to
do justice to it all today I mean I you
know I think
um
many Advocates of more sort of symbolic
style architectures
um focus on the insufficiencies of
current deep learning systems and you
know they're absolutely right those
systems are limited in many many ways
um however
um you know kind of that just because
they're limited doesn't mean that the
solution is to try to build in the sorts
of reasoning structures that you know
kind of we imagine underpin formal logic
or maths or you know kind of the the
formal languages that we use to to
reason about the world and
I think that the success or otherwise of
approaches that do that
fundamentally depends upon the match
between the systematicity of the problem
you're trying to solve and the system
itself so if the problem you're trying
to solve is a systematic problem
you know like go or like theorem proving
then you know of course you can use you
know highly structured approaches and of
course you know of course you know it
turned out that combining deep learning
with research was more effective for go
than symbolic approaches but of course
symbolic approaches are very very
successful for zero-sum games before you
know kind of the 21st Century
but language does have clear
systematicity I mean I I know Bob my
roommate Bob has a friend Jane who once
went to school with someone you know
it's it all resolves to that entity Bob
well so
you know some people clearly you know
I'm not a linguist like I said earlier
and clearly you know Linguistics much of
linguistics computational Linguistics
you know is based around the attempt to
try and systematize language but you
know kind of maybe it's fair to say that
those efforts have yet to achieve you
know full success and you know can of
course Fields like pragmatics and
theories like relevance Theory you know
I love Dan sperber's relevance Theory
right the idea that you know actually
everything that we say is really you
know geared towards mentally modeling
the other and trying to couch our
meaning in terms of their beliefs and
preferences this is not something which
is amenable to the sort of you know kind
of the systematization that we might
give to a formal language I have to say
a real shout out to a book which I
absolutely loved which I read recently
um which is by Nick chater and Morton
Kringle Wilson wrinklesson
in which which is called The Language
game in which they argue that you know
kind of really we should think of
language not as a system of Truth
Discovery but as one of meaning
construction and they they liken
linguistic interaction to a game of
Charades you know when we start to play
charades you know we we will establish
sort of signs which we which become
mutually intelligible by virtue of the
fact you know but they can be very
arbitrary but by virtue of the fact that
they come randomly to Signal things and
that's how language works so they argue
to um to that private language game but
um yeah exactly like bigenstein hey
folks I really hope you enjoyed that
conversation today with Professor
Christopher Summerfield if you like the
work we're doing here on mlst please
consider subscribing on YouTube or
rating us on your podcast listening app
and um yeah just thanks a lot for your
support and we'll see you on the next
one